c'est tout à fait ça pas loin de sochaux
montbéliard à étupes ici donc bah c'est
100% l'oeuvre d'elodie donc votre
histoire et le disent a commencé comment
comment se lance dans la cosmétique
maison alors moi j'ai commencé parce que
mon petit garçon lorsqu'il est né à fait
de l'eczéma et donc j'ai cherché un
petit peu ce qui pouvait être à
l'origine de cet eczéma et je me suis
rendu compte que c'était un petit peu
tous les perturbateurs endocriniens
qu'il y avait dans les cosmétiques
industrielle et donc j'ai voulu m'en
détacher au maximum et c'est comme ça
que je suis rentré dans la mode en
laventure de la cosmétique maison vous a
commencé à faire vous même vous ai dit
tiens mais si j'en faisais commencent
finalement alors ça a été un petit peu
plus loin quand même cheminement mais
j'ai partagé avec les amis parce que moi
j'ai une creative donc quand je fais je
fais beaucoup et puis donc du coup comme
j'avais à peu près dix ans de stock de
savon j'ai partagé et ça a plu et mes
amis ont partagé avec leurs amis ma
famille à partager avec leurs amis et
puis je me suis pas pourquoi pas me
lancer
alors vous avez commencé par quoi quel
était le premier produit alors le
produit le premier produit cosmétique
que j'ai fait en dehors des produits
d'hygiène de mon petit garçon que je
commercialise pas ça a été les
shampoings donc les petits shampoing
enfants par exemple shampoing solide
shampoing solide exactement qui sont
très doux sans paraben sans
perturbateurs endocriniens sens voilà
tous les produits controversé que se
sont déréglées pétrole exactement
donc ça on a les cheveux mouillés on
frotte dessus et tout à fait et sa
mousse et c'est très économique parce
que on ne surdose pas le produit dont
convient pas agressé ni qu'il manque le
cuir chevelu on surconsomme pas et donc
du coup on se retrouve
parce qu'il faut rappeler que comme dans
les gels douche les shampoings ya
beaucoup d'eau finalement on achète en
partie de l'eau on achète on entre 90 et
99 % d'eau donc ça fait cher le produit
actif alors après va vite vous avez
développé donc du dd savons exactement
des savons en saponification à froid
donc c'est à dire qu'on
on préserve toutes les vertus des huiles
via un processus qui dure un mois et
entre le moment où je fabrique le
cerveau le moment je peux le moindre
espace
un mois avant qui les a vraiment tout
certaines vertus donc savons shampooings
dentifrices voilà on a ses petites
bottes ses marques et bio et éthique ça
veut dire quoi éthique alors éthique ça
y est très important pour moi parce
qu'aujourd'hui bio ça veut plus dire
grand chose et moi je veux que mes
matières premières elle soit
respectueuse des personnes qui qui me
les fournissent des personnes qui
travaillent surtout pour mes
fournisseurs
typiquement le beurre de cacao je veux
pas qu'il y ait d'enfants dans la cacao
dont je vais aller chercher un
producteur dans
dans la côte d'ivoire qui n'exploite pas
les saints vont qui les enfants faciles
à trouver non j'ai mis un an à le
trouver et il est certifié fair trade
enfin voila j'ai je demande tout et sa
conception jusqu'au boutiste on peut
dire ça un petit peu moins on est un peu
obligé quand on a des convictions
c'est facile de fermer les yeux donc moi
je ferme pas les yeux bon et bien
évidemment on va vous montrer dans
quelques instants comme aux fabriques ça
sans trop dévoiler quand même le jeu
l'entreprise d'elodie mais on va mettre
les mains dans la cire à